good afternoon everyone and welcome to
this week's episode of the app clinic
this week we are looking at sleep
monitoring and recording at my regular
colleague in Neil Lewis has been hard at
work testing these out and unfortunately
that means he is currently sleeping so
we're gonna hopefully get some of his
input on some of these apps a little
later in the program if he's able to
arouse himself from sleep and and get
them give us some of his insight now
that's just how important we take our
jobs here at the app clinic we're
willing to sleep during the day on a
Friday just so that we can give these
apps the appropriate attention that they
deserve so we're going to look at three
apps today they are asleep as androids
circle alarm and sleep recorder and they
all basically are designed to do the
same thing so they're designed to help
you get a good night's sleep
now certainly the first and last of
these two which we're going to look at
it designed specifically as sort of your
own private sleep study you you get the
device you put it on your bed and it
measures vibrations using the sensors to
see how good a night's sleep you're
getting whether you're twisting and
turning moving around or whether you're
just lying there in a comatose bliss the
middle app a circle alarm is a little
bit different it's actually a an alarm
clock essentially which we looked at
these little while back I was still the
third highest rated app in the category
this week so we are going to take a look
but it is a little bit different from
the other two we're going to spend a
little bit more time on those apps
so getting started what do we really
want from these sorts of apps so what it
really comes down to is we're looking
for something which is really easy to
use sorry about that my poll that's all
right it's always fun to have moving
things uh-huh now it says profile a
device profile wish list at the top it's
not it's actually the sleep monitoring
wish list
that's my lack of preparation getting in
the way there but really what I want is
something which I can startup and it
doesn't take a lot of effort I think you
can get a lot of the requirements for an
app like this which is basically it's a
tracking app in this instance it's
tracking your sleep
but a lot of the same learnings and sort
of optimizations are going to be very
similar to what we've looked at a few
weeks ago when we were looking at
Fitness tracking apps so like those apps
like endomondo RunKeeper runtastic you
want something that's relatively easy to
get going which doesn't take a lot of
attention but then has rich analytics
once you've used it so that you're able
to sort of get started record things
really easily and then spend your time
analyzing the results at your leisure so
the first app that we're going to take a
look at today is sleep as Andrew and you
can see here they've got a feature
graphic whoops just skipped ahead of
myself they have a feature graphic here
which is along the right lines it's a
little noisy and what they've done here
is they've done sort of a classic
mistake and they've used the feature
graphic as a place to put all of their
screenshots now there is a place for
screenshots on the landing page so you
don't need to put them into your feature
graphic now the big reason for not doing
that is that when this gets shrunk down
into a tiny size on a phone for one of
our smaller feature slots it's going to
become basically a mess you know he'll
be able to see these screenshots you're
not going to be able to make out any of
this detail so it becomes messy and not
something which we're likely to feature
and similarly if you're just sort of
browsing here all of the information
that you've got there on the feature
graphic the name the screenshots are all
available elsewhere so I think you
almost want to focus just on what
they've got here and maybe try and make
that more of the feature graphic you
really want to give people on vibe
feel for the app rather than trying to
cram all of your advertising material
all in one place
similarly they've done a reasonably good
job with their icon here it's
distinctive has a distinctive silhouette
it's again it's perhaps not quite
stylized enough it does tend to lose
some of its impact when you get the
smaller icon but it's definitely along
the right lines so definitely good work
maybe a little bit more work to be done
here so moving on once you get the app
going and I'm going to do that on my
phone as well but you can see here
straight away that they've got sort of
the right idea it's got a modern looking
UI it's kind of hollow ish it's not
quite hollow it's not quite an action
bar and that's one of the things which I
really want to highlight for these guys
is you can see in particular on the on
the pseudo action bar that they've got
along the bottom the alignment isn't
quite right so they've got the overflow
icon that looks right but it's not quite
in the right place and so you really
want to think about you know if you're
going to use some of the common UI
paradigms within the platform it's
really important to use them in a way
that's consistent with other apps using
the same controls the same paradigms
where it really gets confusing if it's
something that looks kind of like
something that you're expecting but
doesn't quite work in the same way or
produces slightly different results or
is laid out slightly differently that
just causes confusion so you're almost
better off doing something completely
unique if you want to do any sort of
significant variants on one of the
existing UI pieces similarly we've got
the the little icon on the bottom right
which is kind of kind of cute but it
actually just adds visual cluttering you
can actually see it says home there
which is actually a I think a
description of where you are within the
app either way it's kind of confusing
because is it clickable is it not is it
a navigation prompt or is it just
decoration you know you you really want
to try and keep your screen as clean and
clear as possible now I'm gonna not
going to go into too much detail on the
UI because that's kind of Android design
and actions territory and I don't want
to step on their toes too much but if we
switch to the giant phone if we're
really lucky the giant phone will be
working excellent so you can see they've
got this distinctive UI on the screen
it's got the this bright green almost
sort of similar sort of coloring to HTC
senses UI from at least a couple of
years ago when I last looked at it
you've got sort of the the pseudo action
bar here along the bottom and they've
sort of put the time in that as well
which makes sense but it's also kind of
redundant because I have the time on the
top of my phone up here as well so it's
kind of like I'd rather see the overflow
menu here down along the bottom here
where it should be where it kind of
belongs on Android otherwise it just
makes it a bit confusing otherwise what
we've got here along the bottom is
effectively your tab so each of these
and again this is a little bit confusing
because we've combined the concepts of
an action with the concepts of
navigation so things like hitting the
moon button effectively puts you to
sleep so that's an action fair enough
hitting the the bar brings up the
activity for being able to monitor your
previous sleeps and so it gets a little
bit confusing because what's an action
what's a navigation it should be a
little easier particularly for users you
don't you want to make sure users know
what to expect whenever they're pressing
something on your UI so making that a
little more predictable perhaps using
something similar to Android and in
particular in this layout they view
something that looks like an action bar
but it almost feels like they're trying
to cheat so one of the big pieces of
feedback we often have is that you're
not supposed to have tabs along the
bottom and I'm sure the the explanation
here is all they're not tabs right it's
an action bar you're allowed to have an
action bar along the bottom and it's
true you are but only as sort of the
second half of a split action bar and we
don't have anything along the top here
so I'd much rather like to see this
flipped around so that the action bar
sits on the top you've got navigation on
the left you've got actions on the right
and it's a lot clearer as to exactly how
it all is supposed to work so here like
again we go through your hip you hit
plus it lets you set an alarm as to when
you want to wake up or you can just have
a nap
which is nice and then so if we can I'm
not going to go into too much do
telling the UI in the interest of time
but kind of the key is here when you
press the the Go button and it's going
to start recording my sleep and it's
going to use a variety of sensors in
order to do that and give me an
indication of how good a night's sleep I
have which is nice you know that's
that's basically the whole purpose but
what I think is kind of again confusing
here is that we have an overflow icon
which I'm covering slightly where am I
so you've got this overflow icon and
sort of unpredictable behavior so if I
click this it's going to bring up sort
of this contextual menu bar which is not
really what I'm expecting it's kind of a
dialog where I'm expecting a pop up
overflow menu this the things which
we've got here to set are all fair
enough it's just again though the way
that it behaves and if we leave this
screen long enough it'll all turn off
and go dark which again is nice you can
see here dimming screen touch or back to
return and so this is good because it
means that the phone can stay on and if
it wants to use sensors it's going to
have to stay active while I'm asleep so
it's really important here that that it
does this which is which is nice we kept
back it automatically records everything
which is good so otherwise it works well
it does does what it's intended to do
but I think really the key for this app
is all about tweaking the UI making the
navigation and the actions a little bit
easier a little bit more obvious
otherwise great information around
statistics
well displayed as well I really like the
use of graphs and tables to try and make
this information as easily consumed as
possible I didn't get a chance to check
to see if they have a tablet app I'm
hoping that they do because again this
is a great example where you're going to
use the phone to do the actual recording
it would be great to be able to sit down
on your couch at your table with the
tablet app and really dig deep into the
statistics and the analysis on a bigger
screen
so hopefully the the developer is
watching and they can they can let us
know or possibly some of the other
viewers can know can let us know just as
easily let's move on let's have a look
at circle alarm so circle alarm is kind
of a simpler concept
this is basically just an alarm clock
which is going to let you set alarms in
as an intuitive and simple and fast
method as possible and it's actually
surprising or unsurprisingly enough
quite similar to the redesign of the
Android clock in the latest jellybean
release now we can see here that they've
done a great job with their feature
graphic big bold gives you a stylized
indication of what the app is their
feature graphic mirrors what they've got
here for their icon which again is a
beautiful distinctive silhouette so
straight away the app looks really nice
when you land on an on Google Play gives
you that professional feeling so they've
done a really good job there if we
actually move on to the app itself you
can see that they've maintained that
sort of professional feel throughout
they've got the holo styling everything
works the way you should do and in fact
if we go to the giant phone I'll pop it
up you can see that again it's this sort
of minimalist simplistic approach to UI
design you know we've got an action here
if we hit Plus that lets us it adds a
new alarm which is then if we click into
it you kind of get to the the key the
magic part of the app which is being
able to set an alarm just by dragging
these circles around which these days
now that the the Google built in clock
works along the same lines with these
sorts of circular affordances to be able
to set time it's something that's quite
familiar and quite intuitive so I think
they've done a pretty good job here I'm
not again I'm not going to go into too
much depth because it's it's a fairly
straightforward app in terms of what
it's trying to do it doesn't have quite
the same depth as the other apps that
we're looking at but they've executed in
a really nice way they've put all of the
information front and center as soon as
you sort of touch anything
you get immediate feedback as to what
it's doing you know when the alarm is
set how often what ringtone you want to
use is all put in one place making it a
really simple easy to get started
app and I think that's something which
the other two apps which were looking at
today can sort of take something away
from they are have a much more
complicated set of functionality but
that doesn't mean that the use has
to be equally as complicated in fact the
best staffs offer a lot of functionality
but don't make you feel like you have to
learn it first and that's one of the big
pieces of feedback we saw from the
community as well as our own review of
Tasker last week fantastic app
passionate users who really really love
what's going on there but the learning
curve of trying to figure out how to use
it he's putting people off and I think
you know that really resonated with a
lot of people who watched the show last
week and an Android design in action
which looked at one of the redesigns you
know really resonated this idea of
trying to make it simpler trying to make
it easier and I think that's what a lot
of people want is these apps that they
love to use these services which they
find hugely useful but they want to have
it be easy to use to be sort of more of
a magical experience where you're not
learning a piece of software just taking
advantage of a service so I'm rushing
through today's shows because I want to
I want to try and keep it a little more
succinct than than perhaps we sometimes
do so let's have a look at let's look at
the next app so this is sleep recorder
and you can see here no feature graphic
which is a real shame without a feature
graphic you can't be featured you don't
have a chance of being in the pure
Android collection either and really the
biggest thing here is that you're going
to be limiting your downloads so the
lack of a feature graphic on a landing
page actually has a significant impact
on the number of people who are likely
to download it so and it's not only that
but the quality of the feature graphic
so if you're if you're if getting lots
of downloads is something that's
important to you it's important to have
that feature graphic and for it to be
good now this is an app which spends a
lot of time on design they've used a
skeuomorphic design which you'll see in
a moment so clearly look and feel is
something that's important so it's it's
really an opportunity here to take that
same attention to detail which you have
within your app and put it here front
and center which is basically your
advertising to the world your first
point of impression you know we always
say that first impressions are really
important and that's exactly what you're
talking about on the landing page in
Google Play is trying to make a first
impression
which is going to make people want to
use your app in terms of the icon
you can see it's it's okay it's kind of
the rounded square image which we're
trying to move away from so again this
may be an opportunity to think about how
to make this into something which is a
little more distinctive more a
silhouette rather than sort of an image
painted on a rounded square canvas if we
look at the app itself you can see that
they've gone for a very skeuomorphic
design it looks a lot like a tape
recorder basically with sort of a record
playback and fast-forward affordances in
the middle you've got you know this this
analog indication of your sleep patterns
effectively so it looks kind of like an
EKG mixed with a tape recorder sort of a
lie detector vibe almost since I guess
that's what it puts me in the mind of
when I look at it is just kind of looks
like a lie detector for my sleep so you
definitely feel judged which is
necessarily a bad thing so it is a
recorder it looks like a recorder so
it's definitely on there on the right
track there
they have taken a skeuomorphic design
approach which is quite in contrast to
the first app that we looked at which
was much more of a sort of a clean
hollow based theme and you know really
I'm not making a judgment call on this I
think that both are valid options really
what I'm trying to judge here is whether
or not their design choices are making
it easier for me as a user to get
started and use that up and to be honest
with this app I struggled a little bit
so if I switch to the giant phone here
we go well sleep recorder has stopped so
that's not a good sign I'm not gonna
report it right now but I will hopefully
be able to go back in and record that
for you
so again rate us like sleep recorder
soliciting five-star reviews and ratings
not great kind of obnoxious I understand
that you want people to rate and review
your app and there are certainly ways to
do that but this is the second or third
time that I've launched the app it feels
like this is maybe not the right time
particularly because when I'm gonna be
launching this the first few times is
likely to be when I'm getting ready for
bed in order to record my sleep I don't
want to be interrupted with any anything
which isn't sort of key to that and so
this is perhaps something which you
would display later
while you're sort of viewing the
analysis rather than at the point in
time where you really don't have any
time to spare so I'm going to say no
thanks and you can see everything's
moving around so we've got this you know
beautiful skeuomorphic design we've got
needles bouncing around we've got we've
got rotary dials which I can turn and
what I like about it is that it's it's
simple there's there's no overflow
button there's a very limited number of
things you can do and everything that I
press has an immediate reaction now
where I'm a little bit less thrilled is
that it's not obvious what any of the
things that I'm touching do so I can
turn this and it's going to change my
delay from 1 to 30 but I don't know what
that delay is for or what the units are
so I'm a little bit at a loss like I can
change it but I don't know what it does
and again I can dial this around and it
changes the color on on the on the dial
but I really don't know what I'm doing
so it's it's kind of it's kind of a cool
effect but in terms of feedback it's
underplayed it's a little too simplistic
it's perhaps relying on me understanding
what the analog equivalents of this
design are in order to to be able to
understand it so I'm gonna here I would
try and make it a little bit more
obvious to users who are going to open
it for the first time to understand what
are these things doing how am I supposed
to use them so the one thing which I am
familiar with is the the record button
so I hit record because that's what you
do in fact you know you are going to
take my tape recorder analogy to its
maximum I hit record and play at the
same time but in any case I hit record
and it pops up with a with a modal
dialog of all things telling me that I'm
holding it wrong but I want to start I
don't press record I press the button in
the middle which is a little bit
confusing because well clearly this is a
tip why not why not make it so that the
record button is the way that you
started I'm sure that there is a reason
for it and in fact what I have
determined is that I think basically
these buttons along the bottom
navigation tabs so hitting record is how
I go into recording mode and hitting
play is how I go into the playback tab
so it's basically tabs as indicated by
the depression of the buttons
they go from playback to record and then
clearly I'm already in records of a hit
recording again that's why I get the
dialogue so the fact that there is a
dialog tells me that enough users are
doing this that perhaps this particular
paradigm isn't working for you and
that's I think one of the risks when
you're using something skeuomorphic is
that you really want to be careful
because the record button means start
recording that's how it works on the
analog device which you are creating a
design around so as soon as you create a
design that looks the same as a real
world object but actually the behavior
is different then it gets really
confusing so that's something you want
to avoid and in this instance I think
fundamentally I think hitting a record
should start the recording so maybe
rework the way that those tabs have been
implemented to make it a little bit more
obvious particularly because the analogy
between fast-forward and favorites
I like the alliteration that's cool but
it's not necessarily obvious so it's a
design which really means that you have
to click everything on the screen before
you know what anything on the screen
does and so that's just increasing that
learning curve it means that before I
can decide whether or not I want to use
this particular app of which there are
several other apps which do the same
thing I need to learn the whole thing
first so something which is works much
more like the fitness tracking apps that
we looked at a couple of weeks ago like
endomondo you started up a big button
big play button right in the middle of
the screen I hit that and it starts
recording I don't have to have learned
anything else I don't need to record
anything it's just going to start doing
exactly what I expect it to do and then
I can figure out how the rest of it
works further down the track and so
that's kind of the approach that you
want to take for anything like this
particularly these sleep apps which are
going to you know like I said they're
going to be used when you're ready for
bed you don't want to have to spend a
lot of time learning how the app works
right before you use something like this
to monitor your sleep so if we go back
to the recording tab and hit record
again another modal dialog modal
dialogues are possibly going to be one
of the next topics I look at on
tableflip they drive me crazy modal
dialogues really don't belong in any
operating system since somewhere
in the mid to early 90s if you want to
display information to users there's a
bunch of ways that you can do that and
there's really very very few options or
very few times when you need to pop up
something which blocks their progress in
the app it's really something which
should only be done by by system
dialogues essentially to say hey you can
no longer interact with anything else
because of this reason I'm going to
display this alert so for this providing
a tip it's a good tip you definitely
need to make sure that your device is
connected to the battery connected to
power before you use it but there's
probably better ways to present that
information in a modal dialogue so I hit
OK eventually and okay so now I can see
that the delay was a countdown timer in
seconds before it started recording so I
guess the idea there is you hit record
and then you can you know put it next to
your bed or expect that you're going to
read for another 20 minutes or whatever
else well maybe you just know that you
fidget for the first 15 minutes of sleep
and you really don't want to record
anything until after that so that's what
the what that toggle is now what's not a
hundred percent clear now is whether or
not it's actually started recording now
from my experiments earlier on it wasn't
I thought that at this point the
countdown had finished it was recording
but then there was nothing in my history
so I think no I think it was it was
recording but see now the countdown is
like a minute so it's again the the
theme around this app is basically this
is that it's hard for me to understand
and what it's doing quickly and most
users aren't going to take the time to
sit down and really learn your app front
to back before they decide whether or
not they want to use it they're going to
have downloaded this plus three or four
of your competitors and they're going to
run through them really quickly to see
which one looks the nicest and does
provides the functionality that they
want so you really want to try and
reduce that learning curve as much as
you can so soon again if I want to
switch tabs and it's telling me that I
have to stop the recording before I can
listen to other recordings which makes
me think that what this is actually
recording while I'm sleeping is not
movement so much as actually the noise
while I'm in bed which is an interesting
take so I guess we've got two apps which
look at things a different way one which
is using sensors to determine your
sleeping the other which is using audio
well perhaps they're both using audio I
should probably have checked that more
closely uh-huh
and really it doesn't matter either way
whether you're recording sort of
movement or whether you're recording
audio it's the same principles apply to
to all of the apps it's just which
sensor Hardware you happen to be using
in order to record things and I think a
great app would actually use all of the
sensors everything that you've got on
the device to sense everything that is
changing while you are sleeping so I
think so I can stop the recording I can
go back here and again so this is again
kind of confusing because there is no
recording even though I thought that I
had been recording and and again there's
a couple of UI tweaks here we've kind of
got this iPhone e style buttons
navigation at the top which is again a
little bit counter to what we expect in
particularly here it's a little
disconcerting because you've got this
pure skeuomorphic design on the bottom
and then sort of an iPhone design at the
top it gets just again it's just a
confusing thing for users so I think you
know as useful as the app is the the
biggest thing the best thing that they
can do here is is kind of think about
how that onboarding that that on ramping
is for users you know how are you going
to get them to really understand how to
use the app and see how beautiful and
simple it is without having to spend a
lot of time learning the things which
are hidden so one of the things that
you're going to need to learn if you
want to build an app like this certainly
the first app is around census so motion
sensors is something which we have a
developer guide for on
developer.android.com you're also going
to want to look at how to use the
microphone where I was like the last
step that we looked at to be able to
take in that input and then do the
analysis on that so all of that
information is available on
developer.android.com for sensors in
fact for all sensors both mics and
motion and and and lights and all kinds
of things I think all of which would be
really useful to create a great app like
this
Ankur Tim and Tony did a great
presentation on the sensitive side of
Android at Google i/o last year so you
should definitely check
and they've done some really clever
things with with all the different
sensors to be able to create you know
really inventive ways to monitor things
you know things like I think Tony
actually put together a heart rate
monitor based on an audio input so it's
it's kind of crazy but these are the
sorts of things that you can use and I
would really love to see apps like these
taking that to the next step so that
you're recording everything turning this
all of the sensors on for something like
sleep analysis to determine am i moving
are there noises are there light changes
all of these things are able to be
determined with your phone in fact you
can even record changes in barometric
pressure on some of the newer devices so
then you can create a really rich idea
of exactly what is happening to your
environment while you're sleeping and
create a really rich analysis for sort
of your at-home sleep recording purposes
so before we sign off let's have a quick
look at our prescriptions for each of
the apps and you'll see that the sim
there's a lot of similarities in what
what I'm asking for here so for the
first app for sleep as Android you know
think about a more standard action bar
simple navigation standard ice settings
and just make the whole thing easy to
understand and get started for for sleep
recorder I think again you kind of need
a little bit of a you a UI overhaul it
doesn't need to be completely redesigned
I'm not saying that you shouldn't be
using a skeuomorphic design I think that
that adds a certain simplicity that
works quite well but I found it really
hard to understand how to get going and
I think that's something that you could
really benefit and help increase your
user engagement particularly things
around the the modal dialogues as soon
as you find that you need to tell your
users that they're doing something wrong
that's usually a pretty clear indication
that perhaps you haven't created it in a
way that they find intuitive and overall
just make the whole thing easier to
understand in terms of circle alarm I
haven't given any specific advice there
I think you've done a really great job
it looks really nice provides simple
functionality that works really well so
you know nice work on that so that is
all for today the the quick solo version
of the app clinic don't forget to tune
in to Roman
and Adam for Android design in action on
Tuesday hopefully they'll be setting
their design skills loose on some of the
apps that we looked at today after a
really popular session last week where
they looked at redesigned for Tasker a
couple of announcements for the Android
developer team we have embraced the new
communities on Google+ so there is an
Android development and an Android
design community both available from the
Android developers plus page on Google+
these communities are really for you
guys you know we've created them as a
place that's kind of supposedly semi
official you can create your own
communities and be part of that which is
awesome in this community we're going to
do some light moderation just to try and
keep the spam down and try and you know
make sure that it's a friendly
environment for everyone to be a part of
but it's it's really your community and
it is whatever you guys make of it so
participate take part let us know how
you would like to see it shaped and
we'll see what we can do to help move
things in that direction we also have a
developer survey currently ongoing at
bitly slash Android dev survey so if
you're an Android developer designer
product manager distribution engineer
basically if you have any you know any
impact at all if you're in any way
associated with building Android apps we
would love to hear from you get some get
some of your feedback on the things that
we've been doing and some of the
assumptions that we have so that we can
help build better tools better products
for you guys to have a successful
Android experience now next week there
will be no app clinic we are all going
off to an off-site in Carmel on late on
Friday so we're going to be preparing
for that rather than preparing for the
show we will be back with I think at
least one more episode before Christmas
for those of you who haven't disappeared
on your own Christmas vacations and
we're not 100% sure what we're going to
do so hit up the Trello board and
basically vote for the apps that you'd
like us to look at I think the two top
trending categories right now
I think book readers and what's the
other one Dan remember I think it was in
welcome to labs remote control apps
that's right so book reader remote
control they're the two top categories
at the moment we're going to go with
whichever one has sort of the most votes
for at the top
in those categories so if you have a
strong opinion do jump in there and if
you have a nap in that category
definitely go to Trello self nominate
your app we'd love to do self
nominations and then work with the
developers who we talk to on the app
clinic to help you guys build your apps
make them even better and the the top
ones we're going to put into our own
pure Android collection now we have
three nominees for apps to appear in
pure Android we're going through the
details now making sure that we're happy
with them and hoping to launch that
again before Christmas so we'll
hopefully have more information about
that for you soon so until then enjoy
the lead-up to the holiday period happy
building more apps and thank you very
much for watching I'm reto Meier and
this has been the app blank